[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael rosenbom thanks for joining me
on this wonderful Tuesday or whatever
day you're listening means a lot to me
that you're listening to the podcast if
you like this one if you're here for
Heather langing Camp I urge you to uh
support the podcast if you like it so
much and if you like the interview
subscribe write a review and uh also if
you want to join Patron um patreon.com
inside of you really supports the
podcast my patrons are a blessing Ryan
welcome thank you for having me yeah I'm
really looking forward to this
interview it was good oh you're not
gonna interview interview you oh yeah so
Ryan oh I bet there'd be a lot of
patrons or people who was I brought here
under false pretend maybe we could do an
interview with Ryan for the patron
account just do a quick 10 minutes yeah
maybe I think that would be fun uh just
throwing at you um you could follow us
at inside of you podcast on Instagram
and Facebook at inside you pod on the
Twitter it really helps write a review
it helps tremendously for the podcast
um you can go to my Instagram at the
Michel Rosen bomb the link tree and it
has Cameo where I'm going for
cons all that stuff my live podcast
which inside of you live inside of you
with Michael rosom live podcast is going
to be at the regent theater October 11th
at 800m I think there's still tickets
left meet and greet tickets with me and
my guest Zack Levi it's going to be a
fun festive night a lot of my friends
are going to be there I'm going to be
there I hope you come support me it
means a lot lot it's my first live show
so if I like it it goes well maybe I'll
do more right Ryan we on the road man I
want to be on the I've Been Everywhere
man get a tour bus yeah get a tour bus
inside you with Michel Ros and Mom tour
bus people like get lost just drive
through Amarillo yeah drive through
Amarillo uh and in the inside of you
online store by the way tons of great
new merch and the tville Pod merch talk
uh tville podcast um that if you want to
go for Merch uh we just right now have a
brand new piece of art from the great
May Charter she did our last piece of
art 55 prints made signed by me and Tom
once they're gone they're gone so you
might want to jump on there at tville
podcast.com and tons of cool stuff
inside you online um my guest today is
someone that I have watched for many
years and she's an icon and she was
brilliant on this podcast very open and
wonderful forthcoming and just just
solid I think you're really going to
join this I mean nightmare in Elm Street
where is my poster there it is right
there signed by Heather Lane Camp and
Wes Craven cool can't beat it the only
thing it's missing is Fred
Krueger did he not no he didn't I
haven't had him signed it he was a zoom
interview at that time I'm gonna have
him come in yeah you should I should
that'd be fun yeah but uh she's way more
than Nancy she is uh got a pretty
spectacular story and life and and and
things to share so I hope you really
enjoy it and without further Ado let's
get inside of Heather langing Camp it's
my point of VI you're listening to
inside of you with Mich Ros
B
inside of you with Michael rosenbom was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience hey folks wanted to highlight
something important before today's
episode in case you weren't aware myself
and many of the guests are on strike
alongside sag after and wga today's
episode and any we air before the strike
ends were recorded before it began so
this is just a heads up in relation to
some for the topics we may discuss if
you want more info on the strike visit
Saga
strike. now let's get into
it I've had ANZ for 20 years 30 years
you know what stop upping me I want to
up you on each on everything um I worked
with Wes Craven three times I like how
you start with that that's perfect three
times well I mean jump into that well
first of all I met you at Mike Flanigan
name dropper Mike Flanigan who's an
amazing director writer creator that
Mike Mike
Flanigan um he's really good at karaoke
Haunting of hillh housee Midnight Club
which you were you had a big role in
Midnight Club big role I mean first of
all we met at a karaoke party and I was
just kind of when I get around karaoke I
get kind of you know you you were
watching mine I'm sure you and your
husband were like who is this guy well
you're so good at it that we really
appreciate when people who are good at
karaoke stand up so the people who are
bad at karaoke
can kind of relax in the background yeah
it's kind of like I want everybody to
have fun so it's important for everybody
to sing Who the other guy was there the
big star what's his name from Breaking
Bad Aaron Aaron Paul yes well he was he
was petrified to sing and he got up and
I made him sing and he and it was great
I know my husband and I sang um Baby
It's Cold Outside which is a really hard
song and I wish we had known what a
tough song it was because it has a lot
of syncopation it's a lot of like
tradeoff of the lyrics and you don't
know on the karaoke like which one is
the male lyric which one is the female
lyric and so we switched it which we
thought was really cool it was but you
know what I I do that with karaoke too
like I will I think people like oh my
God I love this song and then once they
start singing they're like oh boy I
don't have that range I can't I don't
know they haven't practiced and uh like
Africa going to take a while to me away
from you I'm like oh my God anybody who
sings those songs you've got to have
practice at least a couple of times at
home yeah you seem like you have a
really good marriage like you guys are
just like two PS in a pod I mean
marriage is is a hard thing I mean it's
it's almost like a horror movie in lots
of ways you get you know you're working
through like lots of things all the time
so I attribute my long lasting marriage
to both of us being
um we're just really patient like when
things aren't going great or we have you
know we we've had loss in our lives that
was really tough and we kind of think we
have this football and everyone's
allowed to kind of just pass the
football off you know and then that
person takes all the responsibility for
a while and then they pass it back to
you and then you take over and and
you're just willing
to you know you're just willing to pick
up the pieces when they all fall apart
but you're always knowing at the end of
the day that where are you going nowhere
you're going to stay right there and if
you just commit to that it's actually
it's kind of easy like once you just say
there's no other options out there I
mean and you cut off all the options
then you know you're really excited to
be there well my sister she had options
she's been married four times and
divorced four times uh those options
weren't always the best options but it's
like you know you got to think about
that I always say like if you're with
someone and then you know some people
get attracted especially actors and
whatever they get attracted to someone
else well it's just the attraction
they're attract you know that's the
attraction it's the physical and so
they're like okay this person has
20% of something that my partner doesn't
have but what about the other 80% that
your partner has which is the important
[__] you know what I mean I never
thought I'd say this but sex really
isn't that important it is but it really
like it BEC it's like you know it's like
you have sex with someone for a year
five years 10 years 20 years hey it's
more about connection and being there
for each other and you know right tell
me I mean I I think you're exactly right
I mean I do think you know sex is really
important but damn it um no it is but
the thing I always I mean I don't even
know I can't even comment on it because
I don't have sex with other people but
um that's good I imagine that it's not
all that different with other people
like my what I tell myself
is it isn't the most important part of
your relationship and if you were really
curious and you were going to take those
chances I just don't think it would be
worth it I don't think it would be like
you'd be like oh my God I'm so glad I
experienc that because this 33 years of
marriage or you know boy I can just
throw that out the window for this one
little tiny Adventure that's going to
last you know what maybe it would last a
month or two it would fall apart you
know it always falls apart you always I
always think of my my daughter like G
how would I ever like how would I ever
have another holiday if if I just
wrecked everything you know if it was if
it was just something I decided to throw
out the window because I I treasure all
the things that come along with a long
marriage which is like great family
events and you you're seeing people from
both sides of the family get together
you you get to know their family really
well they become your best friends so I
think that the longer you're married the
more the chances of you staying are you
know you know they're better I mean
because you have so many benefits of it
yeah are you a cancer yeah I knew it I
swear to God I didn't look it up I'm a
cancer I knew it what's your birthday
it's probably June uh July 18th July
17th you're good is it really you're
good on my mother's life I did not look
that up congratulations it's not here no
I do exhibit all the cancerian yeah
you're a Hermit I'm a hermit I'm a
nester like I love just knowing that I
have a nest I can always go to and I
work on it a lot and and I think family
is like the most important thing in my
life now I grew up with dysfunction so
yeah everybody did well now what sucks
is if I want to see my family I have to
go to Indiana to see my mom I have to go
to New York to see my dad I have to go
there's all these my brethren no one
talks to anybody and so I'm the single
guy so I am responsible for going to see
them and going to and it's it's hard
it's it's hard and you you I
always in a woman if I'm dating someone
I definitely want someone who has a
family someone who is not someone who's
close with their family that they're not
like me where it's all scattered and a
lot of dysfunction I look for some
normaly I try to escape that sort of
idea of chaos which I grew up with but
did you did you have chaos growing up
you grew up on a farm in Tulsa kind well
no so we had a I mean I had a really
like white person privileged upbringing
I I went to you know great school in
Tulsa a little Elementary School I mean
pretty much everyone was white and uh I
remember it was the Vietnam War so we
had some Vietnamese kids come into the
class not knowing any English at all you
know they were just they were refugees
and they just popped into our school
they were the only people not white in
our school how hard was it for them so
hard and um was a very segregated Town
it it still is in many ways so I grew up
there but my dad who his family was like
a third he was a third generation
Oklahoma and um he had a farm that was
outside of town about an hour and when I
was in you know Elementary School in
junior high every weekend that's just
what we did and so I didn't have a like
a typical Junior High experience because
while my friends they would all go
roller skating or they did you know went
out and had parties and went to movies
like I just was out there and we were so
you didn't really you weren't a social
butterfly I wasn't a social butterfly
and I really like was envious of my
friends and all the you know just the
normal life they got to lead but my dad
is had us in the pickup truck early
Saturday and we would go out and you
know we would take care of the cows and
we would you know you milk cow um we
didn't have milk cows we had um you know
beef cattle like uh herfords
and so we didn't milk house but you know
you're giving them shots and you're
taking care of them and taking them to
Market was always really traumatic cuz I
loved them all you know and then you'd
have to take the bull or you'd have to
take one of the cows to the market did
you get emotional oh I would cry big red
did you say why why does this have to
happen why do we have to eat cows but I
still was not a vegetarian at that time
but I I knew that they were going to be
sold for you know meat but it didn't
connect to me like I should not eat meat
and so right L now I actually don't eat
meat but it's not um yeah it's not as a
religious thing for me or a a
philosophical thing I just feel like for
the planet it's really good not to eat
meat right it's amazing how like you got
into the acting thing because I know
your your dad was like into oil and like
worked with like administ
like what the he must have said what
you're going to be an actor you're not
going to embarrass this family totally
that was exactly his attitude no he my
dad was um he was a big fish in a little
Pond of Tulsa and um he was an attorney
and he um yeah you know and he had a lot
of
stature and I think that um he wanted
something bigger so he applied to work
in the Carter Administration he had
friends tried to get him a job there and
he worked in the department of energy
and so we moved to DC for 4 years and
that was just such a mind expansive yeah
thing and I met so I mean so many
interesting people at that time of my
life and at at that time I really
thought I'm going to be I'm going to go
into the Foreign Service I'm going to be
in government I'm going to do something
great you know uh you know in the
government because it's a fascinating
place you know and everything that's
being done is really interesting so
that's what thought I was going to do
and then in that summer between senior
year of high school and first year of
college I had gotten into Stanford so I
was like I'm just going to relax and
Tulsa and just like read a lot of books
and get ready to go to college and and
then that's when Francis for Copo was
there making two films The Outsiders and
rumblefish and so I got I got to be an
extra and then I got my sag card and
those things like just made me take a
total left
turn inside of you is brought to you by
neurohacker our sponsor neurohacker
combines 28 some of the most research
backed neut Tropic ingredients on earth
into an ultimate brain fuel formula
qualia mind it's been changing people's
lives for years now and guess what it's
changing mine um I take this 5 days a
week and I've talked about it before I
didn't even know they were a sponsor
when I was taking it and boy the
excitement on my face and my voice when
I realized I'm going to be talking about
something that I really think works and
that's qualum Mind by neurohacker this
stuff I feel sharper I have energy I
just feel it just really puts me in a
good mood and uh you you really should
try it the formula is non-GMO it's vegan
gluten-free and the ingredients are
meant to complement one another factor
in each ingredients effect on supporting
mental Clarity and you know how much we
talk about mental health and mental
Clarity and all that uh it's also backed
by listen to this this tells you the
story 100 day money back guarantees so
you have almost three months to try nuro
hackers qual your mind at no Financial
Risk and decide for yourself so all my
listeners out there you might as well
get it and try it what do you have to
lose when you could say it didn't work
because it works um you know my daily
mental performance I guess you could say
has been
sharper it's it's it's brain health and
I can feel that and um because I I I
feel sluggish and foggy and and when I
take this I don't it it really it really
helps me fight through the fog I think
uh neurohacker qualum mind is
indispensable and um you know it's cool
to take a product where I don't have to
wonder if it's working or not and um I
notice a difference in just days and I
think you will too so give it a shot see
what one of the best brain fuel formul
foras on Earth can do for your mindset
go to neurohacker docomo for $100 off
and as a listener of inside of you use
code IOU checkout for an extra 15% off
your first purchase that's neurohacker
docomo to try qual your mind with code
IOU to experience lifechanging mental
performance these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
this show is sponsored by better help
Ryan you ever feel like your brain is
getting in the way of living your best
life all the time yeah I would say so
like you know what you should do what's
good for you but you you just can't seem
to do it oh yeah yeah therapy helps you
figure out what's holding you back so
your brain can work for you instead of
against you and this is what happens
with um therapy you're you have all
these things bottled up and you need to
let them out and you need to talk to a
professional it really really helps
therapy is a great way to learn positive
coping skills and how to set boundaries
it empowers you to be the best version
of yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute it's so easy even I can do
it then you get matched with a licensed
therapist switch therapists anytime for
no additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like I
want to try someone else it's easy just
like that better help is truly the best
way to make your brain your friend give
it a try visit betterhelp.com
insid today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com
inside but so you just like being unset
it just it just changed you you're like
I mean you just like oh my God this is
incredible I just want to do this and
you saw you know you saw Matt Dylan and
see Thomas how and Rob low and Patrick
swayy they're all they're all you know
living this life that you just can't
believe that this is a a job you can't
even believe people can make a living
doing it and and this was the time when
you know teenagers like the whole movie
industry was just geared to making
movies about teenagers you know had John
Hughes and everyone just wanted to make
movie about young people and I love that
it was a great time and we don't
remember that like how the focus went
really to the youth during the early 80s
and I mean it's it's not really that way
anymore um no and it was real think
about it I didn't even think about that
but you're talking about John Hughes and
Francis for copel in these movies like
Stand By Me that came out also those
kind of movies Breakfast Club Club um
Rob rer director Stand By Me yeah but
like these movies where it's coming of a
these you know real grounded stories
with characters and it seems like
there's none of that and it's all either
superhero or uh or
what uh I mean no I'm not saying it's
bad I'm just saying well for me I just
miss that I miss that sort of it was
nice to grow up with that and see you
know kids my age and like oh my gosh
look what he's going through a Coming of
Age like rights of Passage was they were
always a River's Edge
what a great movie like all these movies
we as teenagers were watching these
other teenagers grapple with really hard
things I mean you even had like even
blue velvet like they were young people
and they were thrust into like crazy
situations and so that time was such a
good time to be in Hollywood as a young
person because there was so many great
projects always um around you know and
and so the people you know 18
1920 if you're in Hollywood in 1982 you
just you're it's like a feast of
Incredible movies being made and um so I
was like I want to be there I want to be
part of that so I went to I went to
college freshman you know in my dorm and
I soon was like getting you know itchy
fingers like how can I get down to LA
and luckily the casting director for
rumblefish and The Outsiders Janet
Hinson she said come on down and I'll
get you some auditions and we can see
and she helped me get an agent and this
is without like a lot of experience this
was just with my one little extra and
you had not really you hadn't done a lot
of acting I mean only High School acting
yeah in my high school plays but were
you good I mean I I hope I was good she
she had faith in me that's the thing is
that she had a lot of faith and she was
really encouraging she let me stay at
her house gosh casting
director that's that you never hear that
and not unless it's a man wanting to
sleep with
you yeah I know I was so lucky and and
so that relationship really led me to
getting Nightmare on Elm Street and um
you know several like movies of the week
and things like that TV shows and all
this stuff like it all started and it
really just it happened quickly it
happened really quickly I mean things
when you're young things just you know
if you're lucky I was never the kind of
person that was like leaving one job to
go fly to the next one it was always
like 6 months even a year between jobs
unfortunately I always felt like I was
like never getting on that you know the
train of like super success um and so
like once I had that TV series just the
10 of us you know you just think oh
something's going to happen but it I
always felt like H there's like a
roadblocker oh I something's in the the
way like I'm not it's not flowing you
know and and I often would get very
demoralized and just think like okay if
things don't by my 25th birthday if I
don't have another part I'm just going
to you know do something else I'll go to
graduate school or something and then
I'd always like get something and and
but Wes Craven you know meeting
him literally like almost every time I
was about to throw in the towel and quit
I always got a call from Wes and it
would be like I'm thinking of doing
Nightmare on El Street part 3 and
they've asked me to write the script
would you be interested yeah Dream
Warriors I have an idea for you to be in
it and I was like thank you Wes thank
you so much and same thing happened with
Wes Craven's New Nightmare I was I just
had a baby and I couldn't get an
audition to save my life I remember
going out for it was like technician
number three
for you know TV series about you know
things that didn't even have names like
I finally told my agent if the part
doesn't have a name I don't want to even
go you know I just don't I don't get it
because I remember watching nightmare in
Elm Street and your performance was so
like I was just talking to Michael Bean
you know Michael Bean yeah and I was
talking to him and I was like I remember
certain actors the movie stars where
their performances were so subtle and
real and not trying and they just seem
like a real person and when I watched
you in Nightmare it just was you brought
this ground
if it weren't for you as the lead I mean
Wes really knocked it out of the park
because it was like if you would have
got some known actress or it could have
been completely but the fact that there
is innocent girl next door kind of but
real like an actor like I really felt
like you weren't trying you were just
being and what a compliment thank you
well I swear I mean that I think
everyone thought that I think that's why
it still ranks as one of the best movies
ever I mean nightmare El street is one
of the best ever that's why it's right
across from you and that's not
intentional Well w youo wrote such a
great script because I don't know how he
had this ability but he was probably 40
at the time maybe when he did Nightmare
on Elm Street but he just had this way
of getting the lingo and the way that
kids talk to each other it wasn't
perfect because there were some lines I
remember we rolled our eyes like oh come
on Wes kids don't talk this way but in
general there was this casual back and
forth it was really you know great
that's why he was such a good writer and
a lot of his movies you can same with
Dream Warriors there's this casualness
between the patients in the hospital
that it's real and and I think that's
why that movie too is so popular with
kids I think that's the second best one
of all yeah don't you yeah it really
people aren't trying to get out
information you're not trying and so as
an actor you just you know I was as
close to Nancy as I possibly could have
been you know and and and I have a
feeling Wes saw that in me and he he's
like well let's just match this girl who
seems to be just like Nancy and and we
were very similar people how
many how many auditions did you have for
that um I think two one with Wes yeah
one just the reading and then one with
Wes I mean they didn't have a budget man
they didn't have any money so I think
that it was just like we're going to
we're going to pick 10 girls and then
well will come in and he'll pick the the
lead it wasn't let's move on you know
we're not going to be labor this I
remember it was only two weeks like from
the first audition to getting the part
but I remember but my point was about
saying how grounded you were and how
subtle and it just felt like a movie
star I felt like I just like I'm I'm
shocked that like the offers weren't
flooding yeah I I don't I don't
understand that at all I do think that
it wasn't a genre that people went to go
see on their own if they weren't already
fans of horror I do think my the
audience audience was you know 16 to 24
I think all the money they made was from
that age group people across the country
that wasn't uh Executives in the sea
Suite I mean like I would often be told
to take it off my resume like before I
went into Parts yeah they didn't want it
there was just a big stigma still
attached to being in a horror movie and
nobody can really understand it now
because we've flipped 100% but
um it wasn't something that my agents
talked about you know they didn't want
to let everybody know that this was so I
mean I went out for like killer clowns
from outer space like I would have
auditions for genre
movies because they had seen it and
liked it so I did have a lot of more
right that world you were but but did
you want to do that I wanted to do
anything but you really just wanted act
but I didn't really want to take another
horror movie part because I I've always
known ever since that none are ever as
good like there's never as good a part
as Nancy it would just it would be hard
to do that it'd be like you know having
like this great meal with everything
there and then you go and have a Taco
Bell burrito it's like why do that you
know or it could be the second
Godfather which uh some arguably will
say the better one so I mean I would
always yeah exactly and if it was a West
Craven like we talked about with cursed
like he he asked me to do a part in that
and of course I I said yes but in in
terms of being another final Girl part
or a very similar part in a kind of a
similar genre movie I never felt that
that would have been an advantage and I
was I I was you know interested in doing
all sorts of things did you ever deal
with anxiety or depression while you
were you know in your career I mean CU
like obviously you know we talk about on
the podcast but did you ever deal with a
time where you were like all of a sudden
getting anxious about things things you
were like you didn't know why you went
to therapy did you have to deal with all
that stuff or were you just old
school kind of old school but I do I do
recognize like when I'm having anxiety I
mean I I'm the kind of person that my
heart starts to beat really really fast
you know and I can really feel it like I
almost think I can see my shirt you know
moving with my heartbeat but I find that
those feelings are coming
from I mean not so much about my career
much more about like I'm like getting
older time is time is coming to an end
like life doesn't last forever like
those kinds of things will give me a
sense of anxiety like why am I not like
forging a stronger path forward with
what I want to do those are the things
that give me anxiety so in the end I
always go back and think to myself well
why aren't I doing why aren't I making
that hard phone call why why aren't I
calling this person that can help me or
and then I have to really you know
figure that
out inside of you is brought to you by
rocket money this is a no-brainer
absolute no-brainer for anybody who
wants to save money you want to save
money the answer is yes then you need to
get Rocket money as an app um look are
your subscriptions draining your wallet
how many times Ryan do you subscribe to
something and then you forget you
subscribe to it because you just wanted
to watch one show and now you paid $100
all the time yeah the average person has
around 12 paid subscriptions and they
might not even M subscribing to half of
those if you have no idea just how much
you're spending each month you need
rocket money it's this great app that
tracks all of your expenses so you know
exactly where your money is going blew
my mind when I found out but did you
know over 80% of people have
subscriptions that they've forgotten
about 80% and how these this is how they
make their money yeah so by forgetting
by
forgetting they pre on us forgetting and
we're human we forget rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place rocket
money can even negotiate to lower your
bills for you by up to 20% all you have
to do is take a picture of your bill and
Rocket money takes care of the rest
rocket money also lets you monitor all
your expenses in one place recommends
custom budgets based on your past
spending and they'll even send you
notification when you've reached your
spending limits with over three million
users and Counting rocket money
customers have saved an average of
$720 a year stop wasting money on things
you don't use cancel your unwanted
subscriptions and manage your money the
easy way by going to Rocket
money.com inside that's rocket
money.com inside rocket
money.com inside inside of you is
brought to you by discover if you like
like using debit over credit don't you
think it's time you also get rewarded
well now you can with Discover cash back
debit it's a checking account that
rewards everyone with cash back on
everyday purchases plus there are no
fees period we're talking date nights
thrifting the latest trends nights out
with your friends and it's now earning
you cash back with discover cashback
debit check out eligibility and terms at
discover.com
slashback back debit Discover Bank
member
FDIC yeah you know they they did a study
or something where they asked all these
people that were on their dying beds or
whatever they were old people that were
just at the end of their life and and
they said what do you regret and they're
like you know I regret that I worked too
hard I regret that I cared too much I
regret that I was always trying to
please everybody else and not myself
going my own way doing what I wanted to
do and you know I think that's so
important to have other passions but you
found a passion that you probably didn't
ever think you would get into which was
effects and makeup and all these amazing
things right well I mean it's it's
interesting like I kind of think it goes
back to the question of marriage that I
realized that because my husband was on
the road a lot when you know early in
his earlier in his career Oscar award
winner yeah he's won a couple Oscars and
and he was always on the road in these
really great locations like Austria or
he'd be um in New York for a few months
and and and then he had this job to do
Dawn of the Dead um with Zack Snyder in
Toronto and um I thought to myself oh my
God he's going to go on the road again
and I have these two kids
and I'm going to just do this all again
and be at home alone it's not going to
be any fun and then I said why don't I
just like find a job for myself
in your office like managing the budget
or helping with the producers or being
liaison for you so that you can just do
Dawn of the Dead which is was super
challenging I me we had hundreds of
zombies that he was going to be making
and so we figured out um like I will
work in the office I'll do all the
ordering and I'll get all the employees
and I'll do all of that stuff and you
just design zombies and do all that and
so we did that that was like two that
was like the year 2000 and youo designed
zombies youo designed zombies had to be
fast moving zombies right the new style
of zombies and that zombie has to look
like Bert Reynolds or something yeah
yeah and um so he you know having that
division of labor at in his uh makeup
effects Lab at that point in time um
really helped him and um so I started
learning everything I could about you
know doing that job job and so we went
up to Canada and I did it and I probably
didn't do a great job but at least he
could do a great job and it wasn't that
I just loved special effects makeup so
much it just I just didn't want to be a
part and have him every day going 15
hours 16 hours being on the set and so
you didn't really love it I didn't
really love it I mean I love watching
him do it I love all the people that
he's working with but in terms of like
oh my God I just love that effect no
I've never been that person really I
always thought of what I've read is like
this is something you loved it was your
passion but really it was to be to have
a family like and be together wow and so
that's
sacrifice I mean it's also but I wasn't
nobody was calling me to for work either
so um it was it was a hard time when
you're about you know gosh you know 38
an actress in La you know it's tumble
weeds sometimes it's just nothing is
happening so I wasn't losing out and I
was I was winning that whole time
because we we all went to you know we
all went to Vancouver we lived right
along the lake there in a beautiful
neighborhood and my kids went to school
at the little elementary school and I
went to work every day with Dave and it
was and we made this incredible movie I
mean Dawn of the Dead Zack sers da of
the Dead I think is so good it's amazing
have you seen it Ryan what oh my gosh
all the zombies so any zombie that you
see
2002 or two or three whenever we made
that movie are David and Anderson
zombies I mean even I really feel like
he created that kind of a zombie with
the the deteriorated skin that looks
like it's been kind of you know three
months of sort of The Walking Dead feel
yeah way before walking dead yeah so um
wow I think that was about Zack Snider
wanting to create like an ultra ultra
realistic zombie
as if your skin had deteriorated for
this entire period where you're just
looking to eat brains you know and your
skin is still decomposing at the same
rate as it would as if you were you know
just laying on the ground getting eaten
by maggots so that so that kind of
timeline the description is very very uh
thorough very that's why you'll see like
all the the purple the oozing pus like
all of that stuff you know my husband
Dave has to look at so many reference is
of the most disgusting things and um do
you love I like that part do you love
horror um I love I love certain aspects
of horror I really do love this idea
that
people want to be as disgusting and
gross as possible to kind of like go
into where's the limit for that and I do
think we're reaching the limit but maybe
not I mean it seems like things are
grosser than they've ever been so I
don't know where people are going to go
I think working for Ryan Murphy for six
years on American Horror Story like let
me really watch in real time how just
breaking the
tab taboos breaking the taboos pushing
pushing pushing like what's the grossest
thing we can do like how many like
really vile actions can we show on TV
and shock people with certain things
like watching that process was really
fascinating from like a societal point
of view and you know our society I don't
know if it's benefiting from it but yeah
they're almost like numb to it they're
numb to it you know there's a certain
kind of person that I have met over my
career who really loves horror and I I
can't say that they're a type but I know
when I see him it's like I I think that
horror is some kind of a
um it's a medicine for some kinds of
people and I do think it makes them
feel like they belong it's like a it's a
it's like a club it's like a club it's a
club it's a it's a club but it's also
kind of a um it's a Defiance of
mortality like like I'm I I'm I'm
vulnerable I'm weak we're just people we
just have skin protecting us but there's
something about watching horror that
makes me feel a little bit either okay
in my weakness or like somehow buffered
against you know I've never heard that
that's awesome I mean I kind of feel
like I'm in that club I think I'm in
that club too like I'm so weak I'm like
such a little nothing that when I see
somebody getting you know mutilated and
devoured it just kind of reinforces that
feeling and then I'm like but I'm still
here like it's okay I love that your
husband day it's beautiful the way you
said it it's just uh I I I feel the same
way I I don't know what it is I have a
horror group we watch horror movies
every Tuesday night it's me and the guys
and um we dissect them and we always
feel like there's not many good horror
movies anymore and we go through so much
[__] where the boys always leave every
night going well there's always next
week and Rotten Tomatoes say 95% and
their pieces of [__] so I don't know
what that's about and we always
gravitate towards going back and watch a
Return of the Living Dead or a Jaws or a
nightmare in Elm Street or the ones that
just stand the test of time and um they
just don't make them like they used to
and they're just like you know I thought
I feel like in the 80s 70s and 80s these
movies were well thought out like this
is a good story these SE are good
characters now it's sort of how let's do
uh it just seems like it's it's we don't
care about character we don't care if
you like people we're just gonna and the
the best thing about nightmare now
straight is you like these people you're
with Nancy you like her if you don't
like you movie doesn't work so true I
think yeah I mean I just don't know if
the I think the movies are being made a
lot quicker than they used to be made
exactly so that even the actors don't
even know each other that well I mean
I've even been on sets where you don't
even know the person they just come that
day and do their part and they leave and
you've never even even had a cup of
coffee with them you know so how are you
going to have any kind of relationship
on
screen but also I
think people don't want to spend so much
time like developing the character so
even in the the latest Halloween which I
really liked actually they really spent
a long time to to get us to know like
these new people in the story that love
love story in the beginning and and um
and a lot of people complained about it
like God dang it you know spending too
much time we didn't don't care about
those people you know so I think they're
going to die anyway you know I mean it's
kind of like people are just setting up
little people to get killed and they and
there's almost like a video game quality
to it like how many of these folks are
going to die by the end of it and the
kill count and everything
whereas I mean a scary story actually
really
tries to get into your brain about what
we're really afraid of in the world yeah
and I don't I just don't think they do
that I don't think they're nothing's
scary anymore the very few movies scary
everything is scary you know God I mean
I was just talking to my daughter she's
really scared about her kid going to a
school okay that's scary like that's
really scary yeah so make a movie about
that yeah I mean figure it out because
nobody nobody nobody wants to be
reminded that they're real life is scary
because then everyone's really scared
all the time like when remember that
that game War uh the movie War games
came out loved war games yeah we love
that movie because we were all really
worried want to play a game we were so
worried about nuclear Annihilation
thermonuclear it thermonuclear war yeah
but now it doesn't seem like they want
to actually talk about what we're really
scared of um yeah I can't believe your
husband proposed to you on the set of
pet cemetery yeah what the [__] well it
wasn't on the set we went away for the
weekend to the beautiful accadia
National Park okay so it wasn't on the
set of pet cemetery got Fred there no my
husband's so romantic he he had you know
bought he bought a ring you know and he
was looking for a time and a place and
so we went away for the weekend up to
the national park and we never actually
he wanted to like propose to me at
Sunrise which is the first place that
the sun rises in America is at accadia
National Park Cadillac Mountain what
it's the eastern
most Park in America didn't know that
and um so he had this huge plan but like
all
plans well it didn't come to fruition
because he just couldn't bear to wait
that long so he actually proposed to me
like four hours after we'd left you know
Ellsworth Maine and uh that's where they
they shot pet cemeteries in Ellsworth
which did you by the way I know I'm
jumping around but I'm thinking of Mike
Flanigan and Midnight Club and which is
available on Netflix did you how many
times did you audition for that or he
just offered you the part he just
offered me the part
see I mean that really picked me up out
of a really I mean there's this yeah I
wasn't in a funk but I just didn't think
anything like that was going to happen
um so you just got a call one day or
your agent said hey Mike Flanigan wants
to talk to to you well yeah my manager
called and said uh there's a casting
director casting director up here in
vancou who contacted me um Mike Flanigan
has a new show and they they would like
to have you read this
part and uh I said great you know send
it over I'm thinking it's like a one
episode thing and really excited about
it but then I got the sides and the
opening speech of this character it was
like one speech and you kind of get to
know
Dr Georgina Stanton basically um her son
has died of cancer and she's opened up a
hospice for kids with cancer who are
terminal and this is like it was just
her opening speech where she's welcoming
a new patient into this hospice and I um
I get the I'm in I'm like literally on
the 101 freeway getting off at Los
virgin is Canyon Road and I decided to
pull into the gas station just to read
the sides cuz I had to do the audition
the next morning on my iPhone and I just
wanted to like go over it in my head
while I'm driving my long little windy
road over Malibu
Canyon so I sit there and I'm reading
the sides and I just burst into tears
like cuz her story is not my exact story
but I lost my son to brain cancer five
years ago and so this whole this whole
idea that she was this woman who'd lost
her son and had decided to open a
hospice for kids with cancer was
something that just really struck a
nerve in me and so after I you know
cried for several minutes then I just
started like memorizing the lines like
okay I'm going to just get this in me
and so over my windy road and then the
next morning I had to get up and do an
audition and it took me like I'm so bad
at home auditions but they're terrible I
just set up my lights and and uh you
know get my phone and it's like I'm
trying to figure it out and I do I
probably do 40 takes 40 takes went from
like 8:30 in the morning when I started
and then my manager calling me at like
3:30 like where is it it needs to be in
they want it by five and I'm like it's
coming it's almost ready I almost have a
good one cuz it was such a long Mike
Flanigan speech oh my go and I didn't
want to make any mistakes I've talked
about these Flanigan speeches with other
actors that have worked with him they're
they're not easy they do one he likes
one or two takes yeah or and it's just
pushing in on you we not cutting away so
it was um really nerve-wracking I didn't
know that about Mike when I had the
monologue I just thought oh they've
chosen a monologue for the audition and
when they do that there's just really no
way to make a mistake and you have like
20 beats you know you're trying to get
out in this
monologue and if you miss one and I'm
like nope got to do it again so and like
40 takes and you got the one that you
said this finally I just like this one's
it it was like 3:15 and you know you
upload it you get it there and then the
next day they're like great they loved
it okay you know know they're going to
give you contract tonight and and then I
saw that it was for the series you know
seven episodes you just jumping around
the house screaming I was jumping around
the house screaming and I could not
believe it I couldn't believe that my
life had taken such a wonderful turn you
know because I had been kind of in like
this funk like what am I going to do
with myself and um well someone still
sees it you know I mean someone still
sees it someone who's a great he's
brilliant I will say Mike is brilliant
and a lot of people agree and for him to
say yep I I've see her and then her read
you know you still got it I hope I mean
I really I worked I worked so hard on
that show because there were lots of
monologues and I am you know of a
certain age where memorizing is not as
easy as it was when I was 20 so my um my
daughter who lived in Vancouver at the
time I I had her come over I hired her
every day to go over my lines and we
went you know I would work really really
hard on them so that when I got to the
set that day I knew I would do it on the
first take I would never I would never
expect them to have to do a second take
for me and so I I really wanted to bring
that and you know working with such
young actors too I just wanted to set a
really good example how long would it
take you to learn a
monologue I would take you know it would
take like
two three full days you know of actually
getting it down pat without any mistakes
did it drive were you nervous while
you're doing it you're trying to yeah I
was nervous you could already imagine
yourself messing up on set you know that
feeling we get I just yeah oh this is
going to happen on set I'm going to be
the laughing stock that's what goes on
in our heads but I mean it's Mike
Flanigan you know too so it's not just
any any Joe Schmo director you know and
he's you know so important to our genre
and and I know
that the way they work they have to work
work so quickly and it's in the pandemic
so they're they have to even work more
quickly and efficiently because they
have all this protocols for you know no
one can be together and everyone's
shifting places all the time you're not
able to hang and you can't so it's just
a totally different experience and being
in the pandemic with masks and Shields
and how you can't eat together you can't
it's
very I can't even imag Lely yeah I was
on set like earlier this year on
something or or late last year and you
know that the protocols and and and it
just it's just not as fun it's not as
fun it's not like what I always love
doing and you can't like go over and
like you know kid with the focus puller
and like rib him for you know screwing
up the last take you know you can't
develop that Rapport you can't do much
with the crew and then we would just be
I mean there were always oh who's oh
don't worry about it it's probably
delivery or something um
I've always enjoyed the relationships
that I had with crew members no matter
you know what department all departments
and um you know you always walk away
with meeting great folks you know and
that was the hardest part is not having
those like opportunity to meet those
folks and get to know them really well
but I love that you got the opportunity
and you were able to shine you know I
worked my I worked really really hard
and Mike you know we didn't know how
this show the arcs of the show and he
would come in he only directed the first
two and then he was off working on Fall
of the House of Usher right so
unfortunately we didn't get to hang with
Mike as much as I had hoped um after
make the first couple of months but I
did get to get to know him I think
really well and uh I just really admire
I admire everything about how he's
approached his career and and what he
does he knows what his strengths are and
and he and you know he just does that
you know you brought up like you got the
part it just was meant to be it was a
woman who lost their child and it was
something you connected to and you were
like I have to have this and you nobody
knew this role better than you I mean
and Mike didn't even know that ID had
that experience so oh my God that's what
was really when I finally got to meet
him face to face I said you know you
know my sonaus died of brain cancer 5
years ago and he just was like what you
know and I said yeah that's why this is
so weird that we're sitting here face to
face is that there's something else like
I really feel made this part so special
for me how do you I mean look people
deal with loss and you you know all my
father lost my sister and my half sister
passed away like two years ago and I've
never heard him cry and to hear that was
just devastating like whoa and you
always hear that losing your child is
the worst thing possibly that you can
imagine and um I mean how do
you how do you deal with it how do you
deal with it how do you deal with it now
how did you deal with it
then yeah I I don't even know how I did
I
mean I just I just knew that my my my
son had this incredibly Charmed Life he
had so many friends and you know he was
so smart he went to Stanford he you know
worked really hard and he he had the
whole world in front of him literally
and then this devastating news that he
has brain cancer and so it was about 7
years before the diagnosis until he
passed away and you know he never told
anybody that he was sick he never let
anybody know that he had this you know
this devastating diagnosis and just
watching him like rally and just be
there for everybody and all of his
friends be there for him I kind of felt
like I have to I have to follow his lead
in terms
of like just acknowledging that these
these really horrible things just happen
and and we can't say poor me we just
can't we just have to
say you know we're here we got to take
all the advantage of it while we're here
and then when we're not here we have to
know that we've lived the very best life
that we could live so what I always
remind myself of is is that we don't
even know what comes next right like it
could be the minute that you die you're
just right there with all the people
that you know have passed before you it
could be that so you know and so I I
comfort myself with that idea and then
you know the sadness when it comes in
and comes out you just let it wash you
just let yourself be washed by it and
and then you come out of it and it's a
process like it happens you know
probably once a day I mean it's not you
break down frequently I I used to but
now I just you know I have like certain
little habits that I do I have little
pictures that I look at or I have I have
a little Shrine that I address and talk
out loud all of those things help
just you realize that they're here you
know I just really feel like he is with
me all the time and as as if I feel like
I'm going to believe that than it is
true because belief and Truth are you
know very closely related talking about
them and talking about you know not just
like that's the elephant I would tell
anybody who like yeah who knows somebody
who's lost somebody dear it's like the
more that that person can tell you a
great story about them or oh remember
that time when we all did this like that
is like so refreshing and um the people
in my life who really didn't were
painful to be around were the people who
just didn't want to go there and like
they always like avoided the topic and
all I you know I would eventually avoid
them because I like people who can just
say oh remember when we all went on that
picnic or you know he was such a good
guitar player remember when he did that
you know song for everybody because you
want to hear it don't you you want to
like that's all you've got is the memor
so it's all we have right and like I
found a picture I went through some my
dad actually also passed away last month
and I I've been going through a lot of
his photos but you know you'll find one
you've never seen before and you're like
oh thank goodness I found this because
it just brings back this other entire
like piece of the pie of memories that
might be by be gone and I'm constantly
just trying to reconstitute Memories
like okay we went to Hawaii okay that
was so much fun and we went to see that
waterfall okay remember we got lost and
then you know we got all muddy and then
it started raining and um you know
you're just constantly trying to
reconstitute these really important
memories and that also helps kind of Bol
Boler your sense of security that you
know you had this life you had it it was
wonderful and we don't all get to have
dessert you know all year long you just
sometimes get it once it's such a
honestly like a beautiful perspective
that I don't think a lot of people have
that
um or can deal with I think you know
it's I think a lot of it has to do with
like maturity and a certain
like I don't know what it is that you
have that you have this innate sort
of I don't know understanding or sort of
just like I I I what I'm trying to say
is I couldn't handle I couldn't handle I
don't like you could though probably but
like I'm just saying like and I'm not
saying you could handle it I'm saying
that like I don't know like I imagine if
something happened I would just fall
apart I guess that that's how you
probably felt you probably thought you
were going to just fall apart I mean I I
think I don't know what philosophers
said this but they're like the dead
don't know they're dead and the living
you know you just have to manage without
that person that's your that's you you
have to figure that out for yourself why
should you suffer more than you have to
because that person wouldn't want youer
want you to suffer exactly and so you
just have to figure out a new life where
that person's not going to be there
every day but they really are there more
than they were before because you think
about say your brother like did you
really think about him today or did you
think about him yesterday maybe not but
if he was gone you would be thinking
about him every day you're right and and
so in some ways they're more present in
your life being dead than they are
sometimes being alive and that's
something that we think we all need to
really contemplate is maybe I should
think about these living people a little
bit more you know because I'm thinking
about the dead ones almost every day you
know and maybe I'm misplacing my ability
to focus and so I have like been much
more reaching out to the people that I
do care about I do want to make them
more of my present life because now I
know well once they're gone I I can't do
that and we all do it it's the story
that's told over and over is like ah I
wish I would have I wish I would had
more time with it's so sad and it's like
I'm sitting here going I could easily do
this more I could easily you know oh but
I have this I can't have time to make
the time just [__] make the time and
um or I don't I mean if you don't really
want to be around that person that's
also true also like be judicious and you
know like there's a you don't need to be
like great friends with millions of
people you know there're just a few
people that it it really counts they're
there for you do you still keep in touch
by the way with people from Nightmare
and Elm Street or any of the movies that
you worked on well yeah Amanda whis is
really one of my best friends and um she
and I in fact we're going to have lunch
next week so we keep really close
contact and then um Robert England of
course I see him a lot at shows movie
with him yeah he's great so he's you
know he's it makes me sad to see all of
us getting so much older because I in my
mind I don't feel like I'm getting older
but when we're all together we we really
like talk about it a lot like can you
believe 40 years has gone by you know
it's like so much time but so Robert is
a is a I consider him a dear friend and
his wife Nancy ironically Nancy and then
um I see uh J Garcia um once in a while
but when we see like Ira heyen from
Nightmare 3 like we are in in touch a
lot right so Tuesday night I mean she's
a good friend so Lisa Willcox is a good
friend this group of nightmare actors
we've been lucky that we've been thrown
together a lot going around the country
to these conventions and so our
friendships have really blossomed like
toy newerk I mean all these people like
I feel like are you know important
friends and and I could call them for
anything everybody's always said like I
asked around of course and they all said
she's so nice she's such a good person
you know Heather honestly I feel like is
that a curse well no it's nice to be
around people that are like good like
you hear a lot of [__] stories by the
way was Johnny Depp a nice guy back then
such a nice guy he was I'm sure he's a
nice guy now did you think he was going
to be a big movie star honestly no way I
didn't I mean because I didn't tell if I
could not tell if he liked acting or not
because he seemed kind of tortured by it
the pressure of I know that he really
worked hard to be you know Glenn and he
worked very hard on his part and so I
couldn't tell if he was enjoying himself
frankly I mean because he was always so
very dedicated and serious and you know
but you know we all joked around and
cracked smiles and stuff but he was a
musician he was a guitar player I knew
was in a band I thought oh he's just
going to go back to that because to sit
you know in a band behind a guitar and
play music is to me seems so thrilling
and like such a great thing to do to be
able to play instrument like that I
thought oh he'll give this up this won't
this won't keep him you satisfied
fulfilled if you're a great musician
you're not going to turn it all in for
acting you know yeah were you attracted
to him were you like oh he's cute he was
really cute you know he was married when
he did night Street yeah he was married
how old was he he was like 19 he had a
wife oh my gosh and I had a really
serious boyfriend but I mean he was
gorgeous he was gorgeous right yeah
gorgeous yeah wasn't a bad angle there
weren't not a bad angle
and and yet
he just didn't have that ego at all so
you didn't really he didn't you know he
didn't draw draw your attention to him
that him himself that way whereas you
know I had seen other actors like I'd
been around Matt Dylan and I'd been
around um you know some of those Brat
Pack guys and they all had this look at
me I'm so hot you know they had they had
that confidence because they'd all
become incredibly Successful by then and
Johnny didn't have that he was still
like kind of finding his place and you
know unsure of himself so to me that was
way more attractive of course because he
didn't have that crazy ego that I think
Hollywood made some pretty strong ego
Maniacs back then too I would say so who
who do you get Star Struck who who were
you Star Struck when you met them in
your career the one anybody I mean all
of them I am so Star Struck by you and
everybody else out there get out of here
I am that's my that's my whole like
Oklahoma upbringing thing I'm so I'm so
Star Struck by people that my husband
laughs at me because he you know Russell
Crow Eddie Murphy you know Steve Carell
like everyone he is working and the they
makeup artist he's working on their face
he's right there with them and they're
Jack Lemon like they become buddies you
know and um I mean he'll say do you want
to come to the set today and I'm like
I'll just make a fool of myself no you
know and
I you know Super Star Trek by Eddie
Murphy and Russell Crow everybody I just
I just feel like they're so and you're
just you just stand there hi hi you know
and then I go I'm gonna go get some
coffee and then I leave immediately like
I just don't want to have you ever asked
for an autograph um only from William
Hurt I asked him for an autograph really
yeah because
I I really loved his acting I always
um you know I just really admired him
for some reason I guess it was like the
big chill or something something that
movie really affected me and I had a
chance to see him and so um my friend
well
actually um Joan wette and I were on the
the TV series just the 10 of us and we
saw that William hert was like in the
next dressing room like over there and
so we like let's go get his autograph so
we wrote him a note wrote him a letter
like we were in the set next to his and
we would love to know if we could um you
know get an autograph and so he sent it
back with this nice note like I'm so
busy you know I can't really come and
meet you but um here you go here's an
autograph and so it was on a tiny little
piece of paper and so we cut it in half
and she has half and I have half to this
day to this day who has the last name I
do I think I have the hurt yeah yeah she
has got the
hurt but it was a long note it wasn't
just like an autograph it was like you
are so kind to you know want to meet me
and I'm just so busy over here of course
course he was lying I'm sure but um two
two little girls on like a little sitcom
want to go meet you know the great
William oh my gosh I love that I love
that you did all right this is called
[__] talking with Howa laying Camp what
does that mean [__] it's just like these
are these are these like you know you're
[__] talking you're just throwing out
any questions these are from my lovable
patrons patreon.com inside you thinkk
you supporting the podcast okay Patron
uh so this could be rapid fire okay
Michelle K did you have any Freddy
nightm or was working on set not scary
had so many Freddy nightmares the first
ones were like his knives actually would
cut into my face like when we were
working together then later in Nightmare
3 I had this nightmare that we were on
the ship and Freddy is like in control
of it and oh no Chuck Russell's in
control of the ship and all of us actors
are like almost going overboard and I
have to like rescue Patricia Arquette
from this ship
capsizing there's a lot of symbols a lot
of symbolism in that dream that's crazy
um Jamon Jenny met you at a horror
convention with the rest of the Elm
Street OG's and you were really nice
what's the weirdest thing a fan has
asked you to
do there's so many examples of that but
you know when um I mean I think like
signing michet and things like that I
think that's weird but you do it or or
or the knives okay cuz they're Freddy
but you know the machete it doesn't have
anything to do with Freddy right it just
I sign people's you know signing
someone's body for a tattoo is kind of
weird I don't like like doing that sign
your signature or sign this quote I'm
like do you really want to do that to
yourself I wouldn't and not with me not
with my name that's what I keep saying
Raj did you have uh do you have family
or friends that question your decision
to pursue an acting career if so how did
how did you work through that well like
we talked earlier like my dad just
wasn't that excited about it and U my
mom wasn't either but you know what I
just I just kept doing it you know
that's the thing you loved it I just I
never made excuses I just said this is
what I've chosen to do and I'm sorry
that it you know I'm not a lawyer I'm
sorry you know were they proud of you
though um yes they are very proud of me
and the my dad before he died CU he was
too old to kind of watch it on Netflix
he doesn't even know how to use the TV
practically so he went to some party and
he said that he's like I was really
surpris people came up to me and told me
like what a good actress you
were after all these years after all
these years I was like thanks Dad you
know thanks Dad take whatever you can
get that's what I suggest is just you
know whatever morsels of encouragement
you can get take them believe me but
don't expect a lot believe me um yeah to
hear anything from my dad uh yeah it
just doesn't happen Kelly ask which
movie out of Elm Street series did you
love filming the most well probably the
first one right I think I loved
filming I loved filming New Nightmare
because I knew what other film sets were
like nightmare was my first film set so
I enjoyed it but I didn't love it
because I was kind of scared like the
whole time like was I doing everything
right you know I was really worried
whereas New Nightmare everything was
like three or four notches above the
level what we did night new um Nightmare
on Elm Street everything was more
luxurious everything was a little better
and it was fun favorite Freddy quote by
the way or favorite Nancy quote Oh I
mean welcome to time welcome to Prime
Time [__] is the best Fredy line of all
that is I also like that moment with n
with h Tina where he goes Tina and she
goes oh God this is God that's so good
that you that that's sounds just like I
would always do that he like shut up
that one is the most I think like iconic
iconic in terms on a philosophical level
like especially where Freddy's gone in
our culture that one to me is the best
quote but um I also like the souls of
the children make me stronger yeah or
make me strong I don't know ex if it's
that was Dream Warriors that was Dream
Warriors um yeah and he pulls up his
shirt and he has like all the little
screaming faces on man you know
obviously West Pastor were you guys
close did you talk to him in the final
years or any kind of conversations or
not really you know I didn't talk to him
in the final year of his life and I
think he had um you know he he too had
brain cancer and I I do think that he
probably deteriorated to a point where
his family protected him from too many
relationships it's just too exhausting
but um we would exchange a lot of emails
and so when he died we would talk once a
year probably um but we always exchanged
emails if he was there and I'd say you
know what are you doing how are you
doing I heard you you know fell off your
bike or you know what god well he's so
he's so subtle and I remember on set
like him going you know we're talking
about horror movies and I'm like Amar he
goes well you know that's not real and I
go yes it is he goes no it was it was a
hole just it was made up I'm like no no
it was not made up Wes and we're taught
in the rolling camera like you can't say
this to me before rolling Amar go yeah
they they made it all up no there's the
ghost they took pictur anyway he was so
funny and he would always say he was so
he was so like Ry I mean he was like oh
yeah and he would have me like it was
the second time they were filming this
movie so you could tell Christina re she
was nice but she would she didn't want
to be there nobody want to be there I
wanted to be there and I was bummed no
one else wanted to be there right and
you know I had a small part was I just
wanted to work with Wes but each take
you go uh do it like Christopher walking
do it like John malovich do it like uh
Jack Nicholson do it like the guy from
Sil and I went to I told this story but
I went to the uh the uh the premiere for
the movie cursed
and or no not the premiere the cast and
crew and they were showing
bloopers and it was all me and who the
[__] are you I go I just I came in for
like three days and I'm like in all the
bloopers and like yeah it's funny isn't
it like but it was cool he knew it was
going to go on the blooper reel he was
just doing it for that Jesus um by the
way and we're almost done this is you
you good I'm good this has been great um
by the way I just want to know in my uh
hypochondria mine um I'm thinking like I
just want to know at be educated like
what are signs of like are there signs
of like brain cancers or like is there
are there certain symptoms that all of a
sudden you go oh I have a bad headache
and you going to a doctor is is that
what it is I think a bad headache I mean
a lot of people have a seizure like like
a a big seizure and that's that your
brain's like firing all electricity like
very angry that this thing is in there
and so a seizure will sometimes be the
one clue that people have and they go in
and get a brain scan also you know if
you um like suddenly your language
skills like kind of take a dive or you
start falling like there's a lot of
different ways that you can um like your
balance starts to get you know off
balance but headaches too I guess but it
was um yeah I think there's a million
different ways unfortunately really yeah
but I mean headaches are probably one of
the probably a big indicator but yeah a
lot L of people don't
know you
know all over your body you just don't
know what you have you know that's the
trouble we're not going and getting cat
skins and MRIs as a routine so you just
don't know that's what's so scary well
they had that they had that pruvo thing
that I did which is a full body scan oh
yeah I want to do that do it pruvo um
use pruvo Michael or something it's I
didn't get any money for this but I just
I did it and they they detected
something in my throat in my larynx that
was a um it was was in the moderate risk
but they wanted me to get more imaging
so I went to my ENT and he looked at it
he goes let's get more imaging and I got
more imaging and finally it came back
and I was I was okay oh thank goodness
but I was I mean it was but that was
because of you got the body scan but
that was the body scan at least I I had
to know and I did that they give you a
die that you or something uh they gave
me a die not in the pruvo scan that just
detects uh first stage cancers
everything but I think leukemia but then
when I did extra Imaging they wanted to
do the die so they put the die in to
just kind I mean I think as the way
medicine is going I mean it just seems
like these these tests are going to be
more and more available but I mean do
you want to know maybe yes maybe no I
don't know I mean that's the thing it
opens the floodgates for other things
well there's a minor risk in this and
then there's this and then you become
obsessed with it and then you're not
living you know very well but I'm not
I'm not obsessed I was just worried
about that I wanted to get it looked at
and it was fine I forgot about all the
minor things but that's probably why
your voice is so beautiful oh yeah do I
have a good voice it's probably that
thing in your throat why don't I get
more cyst he's got such a syic throat oh
the way he talks I should be doing more
voice over work yeah I know you have a
gorgeous voice really thanks yeah a
gorgeous voice in these cans they sounds
nice yeah and these cans um anything
going on anything next well you know our
show got cancelled was really sad and so
um I I just did a little part for a
friend and um Mark deala he has a film
called stab at Heaven that I got to play
the mother of a of a girl who's
wrestling with her her boyfriend has or
fiance has committed suicide and so it's
kind of a not an uplifting movie it's
very very philosophical and
contemplative but he's a he's kind of a
worldclass photographer and he's taken
his directorial Ambitions into film
making soil look good it looks so great
great and um but I was really nervous
about it you know again you just don't
feel sometimes you just don't feel
confident and um that's acting you
sometimes it's on sometimes it's not
quite there and you got to fake it yeah
some you got to fake it so but I yeah
that was really fun to do but I'm
looking for work and um I'm looking
everywhere but also too I just I feel
like there's something about it I just
feel like I'm in this waiting mode for
some reason I don't know why but I feel
like I'm waiting and I'm anticipating
something to happen but like I said like
I just need to pick up the phone more I
think well you know I mean you just did
a whole season of a a show it didn't get
picked up for a second season but
everybody knew about it Netflix Mike
Flanigan he loves you you just did that
it's not like you like oh it's been six
years I know you me it was like that
before so I wanted I want to like not
let this this is a thing I don't want to
let just die on the vine I I want to see
this you know create more opportunities
and that's that's kind of where I'm
sitting right now thinking what
opportunities do I want because I do
think you can ask for the opportunities
you want absolutely you don't want the
ones you don't want and there's nothing
wrong with making some calls nothing
wrong with sending some emails there's
nothing wrong with that kind of stuff
there's nothing wrong with working with
a first-time director if you like you
know he's got passion or whatever right
so um yeah this has been a real treat
well thank you so much for having me I
really loved it I really I mean I've had
Flanigan and um I've had uh Robert
England and um you know yeah this is
this has been fantastic the last thing
I'm going to do is afterwards I'm G to
ask you to sign that if I can get the
poster out I might not be able to get
the poster yeah you might not well it
looks like you can it's like it doesn't
look like it's it's cheap say just say
it it's cheap say it's a cheap frame
it's a cheap frame it's uh most of my
friend The Lost Boys is the worst but
it's the only frame I can find that
would fit there yeah but you know like
all the posters are different sizes like
they they're not standardized I don't
know who made that up do you have an
original uh nightmare num Street poster
nope I bought it at
allposters.com they're not paying me to
say that either that's an original by
the way don't look but what does you
mean original like original poster from
like 1984 yes from the movie theater
orever how do you know because you know
there's there's way yeah there's ways of
looking at it there's things that you
could do I think that it's all I know I
know you know how many people bring me
gloves and say this one was an original
that was worn in great and then I'm like
I'm so happy I so happy for you of
course I would never say like yeah right
oh good one yeah original huh yeah so
many people gosh do you know do you know
the tagline don't
look um if Nancy doesn't wake
up if Nancy doesn't wake up no I forget
what if Nancy doesn't wake up screaming
screaming she won't wake up at all w at
all that I mean look at that I mean you
I know it's such a great great great
poster well that poster artist you know
did all the nightmare posters and
Matthew oh what's his last name but he
just uh one of the poster companies just
released that poster in a much more Art
House kind of you know way and um it's
beautiful but it doesn't even capture
the colors that are on that poster which
the old school posters were just amazing
yeah they always yeah and they I mean
they worked hard to get all the themes
all the feelings of the movie you know
they work that is hard yeah this guy's a
genius he's a genius he's a genius and
he's a very nice guy too um anyway I
thank you for having me thank you this
has been a joy a joy next time at the
karaoke bar what will we sing Endless
Love oo I love that song but what about
ain't no mountain high enough ain't no
mountain high I think after the first
time we sing we're like why are we doing
this it's one of those we're like oh boy
that that range is way out of our
range what other good Duets are there
from the 80s there's like in the stre
Islands in the
Stream what was the one oh no what one
time of my life will I had the time of
my life see he's so much better at see I
never feel like this before never found
I
swear here a see all right we've lost an
audience
thanks you're awesome great Michael
thank
you
man I'll tell you I wish I was as easygo
and could just handle things like she
did I mean dealing with loss dealing
with just uh facing adversity and just
keeps going and working hard and is a
wonderful human being at the same time
hasn't gotten nasty she's not nasty you
know people can get nasty and uh I think
she's been through it and um she knows
who she is and it was a pleasure having
you on the podcast Heather thank you
sorry it took so long to air it
but it's
here um hey just a big shout out again
the live podcast inside of you with
Michael Rosen live podcast is October
11th at the Regent Theater downtown
tickets are available go to Instagram my
Instagram at the Michael Rosen bomb the
link tree Cameo the live podcast you can
get tickets they're still for sale still
for sale Zack Levi is the guest um and
all that stuff so thanks for listening I
appreciate it and uh I think without
further Ado we need to get into the top
tiers what do you think Ryan I think
that's a great idea all right we're
going to read them I'm going to read
them I'm going to do bad impressions of
people have never done Impressions and
you have to guess who the impression is
and they do it fair enough Nancy D liia
and Kristen little Lisa Yuka Jill e
Brian e is this a Christian Bale
character kind of that's what I was
going for Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie
M Ross C was it the prestige is that
with that maybe I don't
know he always talks like
this now you have to go you have to read
it like that oh like what Joshua D
Joshua D Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal f
Janelle B Ashley Ryan Mike E Elan
Supremo Elan Supremo 99 more San Diego
m
b Maddie s binda
in DAV H I don't know who this is
nobody you said chillogy I said chy oh
wasn't great but I I tried
sheit Fred D Ray H tabi the T Tom n tal
M Betsy
D Angel M Ranna C Cory K Dev Nixon
Michelle a Jeremy C yours is better
Michael Kane I can't do it Michael Kane
a ruby the size of a tangerine that's
really good yeah all right you said
Jeremy C Jeremy C all right um
well Brandy D Joan M Joanie
B Joey M Joanie
B Eugene and Leah Cory Angela F I can't
do this one but that's a very good War
Freeman you can keep doing it Mel s
Christine s Eric H Shane R Andrew M
Amanda R Jen B Kevin e Stephanie k
I remember the first day when Andy came
to char shink Jerell jam and J lean J
Luna R Mike F Stone H Kayla stay wild
moonchild Brian L Kendall L Caris C
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P Kaylee J
Brian a Ashley F Maran Louise L Romeo B
Veronica Q Frank B Jen T Nikki L April R
Derek n j DW com bomb Ginger Insomniac
Rachel d laurelai l and Melissa
H guys thank you um I love you thanks to
all my patrons out there patreon.com
inside you if you're still here
listening from the Hollywood Hills in
Hollywood California I'm Michael
rosenbom I'm Ryan T all right little way
to the camera we love you guys be good
to yourself I'll see you next week
please come
[Music]
back